I'm really excited and I'm very, very honored to be a
captain of the Wildcard Club.
I honestly, I'm just really happy to be a part of something
so special.
I am so excited to join the Wildcard Club.
I'm very excited to make new memories with everyone and
maybe meet some new people as well and hear their stories
and their experiences and make something together.
I believe we're like, I'm an old.
Oh!
Grandma.
Join my team.
It's the best team, guys.
Our team's going to be the coolest team out of all the
teams, guys.
So join my club.
That's so.
Yeah.
Yes.
All right, Grandpa.
Let's get you to that.
As team leader, I swear to bring this team to the nationals.
We're going to win the Super Bowl.
Go team.
Wait, is no one going to interrupt me?
Wait.
Do I have to hold the ball?
this post till someone comes to interrupt me like the last
two times but am i really that unpopular oh man when
i first started v2 being i would like stream with like other
different models and i would just wear a different model
like almost every day and i first started i was like i'm
just doing it for fun it's fine then i started thinking
about i would like to be like myself and not just be like a
random anime character and i made my persona it wasn't until
later that I decided this is who I'm going to be.
So I feel like I almost had like two debuts.
I had like the small debut where I was just messing around
and not really myself.
And then I had my second debut, which was my debut debut
when I debuted my real self and my real model.
I was a little bit more shy because I wasn't too confident
in myself.
When I became a VTuber, all that started changing because I
was Iron Mouse and I felt like...
It was almost like I was putting on superhero costume and I
became a version of myself that I felt more confident.
So I started talking more and I started expressing myself
more.
Now, some of you may be aware, I didn't always used to look
like this.
I have been in the original design since 2022.
And sometimes your taste might change.
And with V-Tubing, you have the freedom to go, changed.
Time to change my face too.
I think one of the important things to remember about my old
design was that it was kind of a reaction to the way that
VTuber agencies typically did things.
And, you know, I'm independent now, so that's not really my
fight to fight.
I've kind of been through all of that.
I proved my point.
I did it.
Good job, Rin Penrose.
Freedom means I'm free.
So now I decided, you know what?
It's time to do something that's a little bit more in tune
with my current taste.
It's time to get a weirder haircut because I'm in the middle
of a midlife crisis.
So I brought in like an actual proper character designer.
Her name's Hen.
And I kind of went, here is a Google document with
everything I have been working with.
Please God make this work.
It was initially daunting to receive a PowerPoint
presentation.
When I checked it again, it was 25 slides.
I can tell that Rin had the vision.
So it was my job to help turn that vision into a cohesive
design.
Now the funny thing about this rebrand is that it came in a
bit of a weird time.
Saturday is the re-debut stream, and Sunday is a meet and
greet at a convention where a lot of people are purposefully
stopping themselves from seeing my new design because then
they want to be surprised in the moment.
So I had the wonderful experience of being at this meet and
greet as we're in Penrose too and people walking on in to
the booth and going oh what you done there
let me go change real quick into my into my old suit it's a
little fucking dirty though give me a sec guys all right got
change into my old suit just like old times There I go.
All right, guys.
So before then, I had this different design.
It was before everything when I was just an artist streamer.
We call her Retro Doki because she's old.
Why did you change?
Why did you rebrand?
She was so, she's so cute.
I'm cute too.
Like right now I'm cute.
But basically it was because she didn't really fit my
current vibe.
Who wears a dress during war?
Like, when you get shot at, you know?
So, I want to be, like, convenient when I'm, like, running
around and stuff and going, pew, pew, pew.
Thing is, I came back as Doki Bird.
So, like, I had to be a bird.
So, what can I do to be more like a bird?
So, obviously, it's the hair.
So, you can see, like, my little feather-like hair and
stuff, which is I'm really happy about that and makes it
really unique and everything.
It makes me look so cute.
And then I guess like the hardest part
for me was just being like, I hope people like it.
Because I was just like, people really liked Retro Doki
because they're like, oh, she really fits Retro Doki.
She looks so smug and everything.
I was like, what if they don't like it?
Like, what am I gonna do?
I spent so much money.
Like, I can't like debut this and just be like, JK, I go
back to Retro Doki.
So I was so scared.
I was so scared that people were gonna hate it.
But I'm glad, you know, I'm still here.
So that means people liked it.
I'm happy, I'm happy with who I am now.
You know, retro doki is still a fan favorite, and sometimes
I jump between that, and I have different types of me's too.
So even if you don't like bounty hunter doki, don't worry,
there's other doki's out there in the world that you might
like.
If you go back and watch my very first streams, it's a
character.
I wanted her to be a cool, baddy, villainous character.
I think this form suits me well.
What do you think?
Here I am, in all my glory.
It's been a while to amass enough power to appear before
you.
Monarch, very, very stoic.
She's very elegant and poised.
I don't show my true self, which is obviously very silly and
quirky and girly and friendly.
It used to make me so scared and nervous when we would have
tech issues, when the stream wouldn't work or when like the
VTuber would lag or something.
And I'd be like, that's it.
I'm quitting VTubing.
I'm not gonna do this anymore.
I can't do it.
But chat loved it.
I remember this one chatter said, ah, the content we tune
into.
And I was like, wait, they love when I'm a mess.
I don't have to hide mess.
They love the mess.
Mess is the content.
It just made it feel more relaxed.
Like, I was like, whatever happens, happens.
Like, they're here for the ride.
They love me for me.
I don't have to pretend in a way.
One thing that I realized is when I was doing covers, I
didn't have a lot of interaction with fans.
Mostly I would work alone, work solo, upload a song, and
they would comment and that'd be the end of our interaction.
But with streaming, they come into chat and we have jokes
and it's more of a one on one connection.
And I really love that about streaming.
It's it's more personal.
I think the people know that there are humans behind the
avatars.
People are expecting to have the word with a temperature,
the word with a heat.
I think that's the reason why people are tuning into VTubing
streams.
exist here to entertain people for having struggle or they
just need a little smile in their life right i think a lot
of people are able to take our joke and able to laugh
because we talk about a lot of the in real life stuff
youtube is a medium to connect people is so interesting now
bob and now more than ever i feel like people are
appreciating the real human connection when you can get it
online you know seeing someone else on the other side of the
world be into the same or same video games as me is still
really a powerful connecting factor.
Today people come to me to conventions and they're like, I
actually found my favorite anime through your covers in a
way.
And I was like, oh, I'm so happy to have introduced you to
my own loves and to have shared them in that way with you.
It just means a lot to me.
I think, by the way, that I somewhat rejected the kind of
normal expectation to be a little bit girl-friendly, as the
girly pops say.
I ended up fostering a very different audience than a lot of
people in my position.
Some of the responses to the stuff I do that I remember the
most is genuinely, I get a lot of folks who are kind of, you
know, they might be Aero Ace, they might be some other
orientation that isn't represented super commonly,
especially in like the V-tubing scene.
And I just get a lot of people who are like, hey, this
helped.
It is nice to see another ace person on the internet.
That was cool.
It does help to know that me being a silly guy on the
internet, weirdly enough, does a little bit of good
sometimes.
Yeah, I think that VTubing connects people in the real world
on so many different levels.
I feel like it hasn't been around for too, too long if you
compare it to things like anime and manga, but you already
see so many VTuber fans getting together and hanging out and
I think that it's really amazing that there are so many
folks out there that who otherwise never would have met have
gotten to be friends over a shared interest.
I'm really glad that we've gotten to bring so many people
together.
It's one of my great joys in life, I would say.
I call my community my precious family because even though
we're larger now, I still feel like they are my family.
I don't know.
Maybe that's a little bit parasocial of me and It's wrong,
but to me, I like to call them my precious family because I
feel very close to everybody every time I stream.
And now I have friends that I'm so grateful to have them in
my life.
Iron Mouse is the kind of friend everyone hopes to have in
their life at least once.
She's loyal, caring, thoughtful in ways that most people
never get to see.
Over the years, our friendship ruins at something much
deeper than either of us probably expected.
She became family, not in the casual sense of the word, but
in the sense that she's someone I would show up for without
hesitation, no matter the circumstance.
It's the Internet saved my life, basically.
The act of graduating and reincarnating made me realize how
little of an importance your name and face is.
It goes so much deeper than that.
What truly matters is your ability to touch your fans and to
touch other people's hearts.
It's kind of romantic to be able to find someone that you
loved and you supported and you find someone with the same
exact voice and the same exact soul.
It's a really emotional and honestly a really important.
VTubing means everything to me.
It saved my life and I hope that it's something that I can
grow and be a part of forever.
When I first came back after everything, I literally thought
my career was over.
So I had basically rebuilt everything from the ground up
again.
I was like, what am I gonna get all these opportunities?
Am I, is people gonna care about me?
The thing and that's like a big fear of mine.
I'm glad to be proven wrong because there's so many people
that came to support me and there's still so many people
came to support me till now as well, like in the present,
past, present, and the future.
And I really appreciate that.
That's why I want to work really hard for them as well
because they were there for me and I want to be there for
them too because without them, there wouldn't be a
Dokeybird.
I feel like that is what the show is all about.
You're watching the Wildcat Club You have a place here.
You have so much fun!
With me, of course.
Welcome to the Wildcard Club!